So there's a significant portion of my audience
that is also going to be furious that I'm
even covering this next story. And again,
I don't care. I, I, I've, I've decided if
you want to do whatever you want, dislike
my videos, whatever, this is an important
story and we're going to talk about it.
The Bernie Sanders campaign has been notified
that Russia is trying to help him similar
to their effort to help Trump in 2016. That's
the, uh, the assertion that's been made by
intelligence to Bernie's campaign. They've
also briefed Trump about this. Now there are
people on the left who believe the entire
Trump Russia story is totally fake and they
believe this story is also totally fake. You
and I don't have very much to discuss the
case. I want to make today is that of course
Russia prefers Bernie to be that the democratic
nominee, basic geopolitics would dictate that
and instead of weirdly denying it, progressive
should instead say, Russia always has preferences
and they have really slick ways of acting
on those preferences and we should be glad
that Bernie reacted to this in exactly the
right way. He is doing this the right way
as opposed to how Trump did it the wrong way.
Now before we move on, I don't want to ignore
that. It's problematic that there are people
that think it's a problem that I'm even talking
about this. I get that's a problem. It's hugely
problematic. I just don't have time to deal
with that aspect of it. Today. We're in the
middle of trying to remove Trump. We're falling
behind on climate change. People are dying
from not having healthcare. If you want to
dislike the video, go ahead. You want to say,
I never should have talked about this. Go
ahead. I, I, I'm doing the stories that I
want to do and I'm going to do them the way
I want to do them. We can disagree respectfully.
That's great. Diversity of opinion is fantastic.
So here's the situation. Us officials have
warned Senator Bernie Sanders that Russia
is attempting to help him in his presidential
campaign and are generally speaking, interfering
in the democratic contest.
Trump was informed about this. We don't yet
know all of the ways that this is being done.
Social is a big part of it. We have a report.
We're working on our own subreddit, the David
Pakman show, sub Reddit has been plagued by
pro Bernie sock puppet accounts recently accounts
created an hour before that. Then post the
same divisive pro Bernie messages to 40 different
subreddits. We're getting hit hard by them.
That's a piece of it. Now, Bernie Sanders
reacted the exact right way. Bernie Sanders
when told about this and asked by the media
said, I don't care, frankly, who Putin wants
to be president. My message to Putin is clear.
Stay out of American elections and as president,
I will make sure that you do notice the difference
between reactions from Bernie to Trump. Trump
has told Russia prefers him. He denies it.
Sometimes he says, Putin said it wasn't true,
even though Putin has publicly said it is
true.
He then asks Russia to find Hillary's emails.
He then lies about contacts with Russia. Bernie's
told Russia's helping him and he says, I don't
care. Stay out of our elections and when I'm
president, I'm going to make sure that you
stay out of our elections instead of wildly
denying that this is a thing progressive should
say, Russia has an angle. They are known to
do this all over the world. We are paying
attention to the democratic primary right
now. Bernie's handling it the right way and
Trump handled it the wrong way. Now let's
talk about the Russian motives here. Of course,
Russia wants Bernie. Russia's priority is
always to push for what will be most destabilizing.
What will be the biggest shakeup to the status
quo. They are experts on sewing chaos and
confusion. In 2015 and 2016 the Republican
establishment didn't want Trump. Russia recognized
that reality show host Trump would destabilize
the Republican party.
It would turn the primary into a sideshow.
If Trump was the nominee and then was able
to defeat Hillary, it would be embarrassing
for the U S it would be hilarious chaos for
the U S it would allow Putin to maybe look
more powerful and strong geopolitically in
2016 during the primaries, the, the most status
quote challenging event would have been a
Trump nomination, a Bernie nomination on the
democratic side once it became Trump versus
Hillary. Supporting Trump would obviously
the be the most destabilizing thing or event
that Russia could support this time around.
The only thing as rattling, uh, to the status
quo as a Trump reelection would be a Bernie
nomination. And or Bernie becoming president
of the United States. This doesn't mean Bernie
will do bad things if he's president. This
is just what will most shake up the status
quo. So we look dumb when we just deny the
reality that it's obvious why Russia would
prefer Bernie be the nominee.
It's not secret. Check out the book from the
1990s foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
do. Again, this is not a show that's going
to feed you conspiracies or whatever. I don't
know what anybody else is saying about this.
This Bernie Russia thing. When we look at
this, which democratic candidate would most
rattle the democratic establishment? It's
burning. That's why a lot of people are supporting
Bernie. Recognize that. That's why it would
be attractive for Russia to try to help Bernie,
which democratic candidate becoming president
would throw the U S into a situation that
would be the most different from the status
quo. It's burning, right? Is he an actual
social Democrat? Calls himself a democratic
socialist, which can did it. Did Trump actually
say would have been the toughest to run against
back in 2016 Bernie, if you're Russia, you
obviously support Bernie in the primary and
then in the general you have your pick, right?
I mean, if Trump wins reelection, it's another
four years of international embarrassment.
If Bernie wins, you get a real shake up to
the status quo of the types of people that
have been president of the United States.
Bernie does a lot of good things that I agree
with, but Russia's goal is change the status
quo. Destabilize. Look at how the centrist
Democrats are going crazy about the possibility
of Bernie being the nominee. Of course, this
is what Russia wants. Doesn't mean there's
anything wrong with supporting Bernie would
not make it.
Bernie win and you less legitimate and Bernie
is handling it the correct way. Let me know
what you think